you know the older I get the Dumber
things look around me sometimes the this
idea that some of you have bless your
little hearts you have not lived long
enough to realize that communism is a
complete freakin failure I just read a
review of a guy going through Cuba
he visited Cuba the other day one of my
my son went to Cuba this summer he
decided that was a cool thing to do
Cuba is basically right now an armpit
it's it's a Caribbean nation it's been
run by the Russians and the highways
look like you're they were carpet bombed
there's no hot water there's no toilet
seats there's no soap and running water
in most of the country people literally
go down the main highways with ox carts
this is how communism works and yet some
of you little twits that are in college
still think communism is a good idea I
mean really you can find no tangible
evidence that it has ever worked
anywhere for anyone except the three
people that run the place and they put
all the money in their pocket but for
the little man communism has never
worked you cannot find a socialist
country a communist country that has
economically prospered for the little
man for the average person there's no
evidence and yet people still think it's
a good idea it's interesting man it's
the fun thing about the Internet is you
get you just get hammered with
information and some of its true but I
was just reading this review of Cuba
which was funny this is sad is
everybody's all enamored with Cuba Cuba
this and Cuba that and just tell you
there you know I mean go to Mexico it's
a lot better or better than that stay in
the States it's a whole lot better in
terms I mean really the Hampton Inn
actually has whole toilet paper in it
it's an amazing thing and most of the
time they don't steal your stuff I mean
it's amazing thing this is this country
we live in and we just take it for
granted so
you know you got that on one hand and
then the next thing I read is this this
little hipster twit who says why do
people at McDonald's make less than a
heart surgeon because we're not
communist let's answer the question the
only way that a heart surgeon would make
the same thing as a person at McDonald's
is because we're communists we take on
the Communist economic form of operation
because that's the only place that says
everyone makes the same amount of money
oh except the people on the government
who run everything and they take all the
money so let's just keep in mind very
very wealthy people in Russia just a few
of them but very wealthy people so
income in capitalism what what little
twitter twitter twitter whatever we call
the hipster that's a twit um is saying
is that that's a new term I just made up
a new word um that's pretty cool at
whipster a twit that's a hipster yeah
there you go
all right so what he's saying is that
it's unfair that a heart surgeon makes
more than a person in McDonald's and I
would submit to you that it would be
unfair if they made the same amount
because the amount of preparation the
amount of study the amount of years in
school the amount of dollars spent to go
get that education for the heart surgeon
is a bazillion times more than the
person working in McDonald's so to pay
them the same after one has spent
decades preparing for their career and
one spent 20 seconds preparing for their
career to pay them the same would be
unfair if a man works eight hours a day
and another man works four hours a day
it would be unfair to pay them the same
wage to pay that to pay them the exact
same amount for a day's worth of work
because one only work to half a day well
we wouldn't do that well it's the same
thing darling it's the same thing and so
for
wealth to be all equal in the name of
it's not fair
it actually would be unfair because some
people are prettier than others some
people are smarter than others some
people run faster than others some
people study harder than others some
people work harder than others some
people come up with better inventions
than others and so they should make more
I'm not as smart and successful as Bill
Gates but I'm not jealous of Bill Gates
I don't have his intellect I did not
change the world with the personal
computer
Bill Gates changed the world literally
with the personal computer you can like
him or not like him
you can think das is better I don't you
you know you can think Apple is better I
don't care what you didn't know the
bottom line is the guy changed the world
and so he earned his money and then some
it would be unfair for a guy who owns
one a gal who owns one restaurant to
make the same as someone who owns ten
restaurants that would be unfair by
definition so don't tell me it's that
wealth inequality is unfair of course
wealth inequality is fair it's required
to be fair otherwise you would never do
anything and you would be communist and
your country would run that way you know
what the unemployment rate is in Cuba
doofuses forty eight percent half the
people don't work and oh by the way the
ones that work they don't work forty
eight percent this is how communism
works oh you know don't primary think
Marxism is wealth equality by the way
it's unfair that the little man that
we're the governing people are gonna
band together and make sure that the
little man is taken care of that's Karl
Marx or I read it this is a manifesto
and yet we still got
twits Twitter's believe in this stuff I
guess it's just part of going to college
with communist professors I guess that's
where you get that but I mean you would
think communist professors would be
intelligent enough to actually study the
data that there is no such thing as a
communist socialist country that has
been economically successful over an
extended period of time there is no such
thing it has never worked and really
there's not nothing much more
capitalistic than a good communist
because they figure out a way to work
around the system and sell something for
people they don't believe in capitalism
boy they are capitalistic as they can be
you wanna be capitalist meet a Chinese
they're the most capitalist communist on
the planet they're more capitalist than
capitalists are think about it
don't be stupid people it just makes you
look stupid
this is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]